die frage ist einfach sollten wir jetzt
sofort aufhören gas öl und kohle aus
russland zu beziehen ja oder nein
energieimporte einstellen wegen des
angriffskrieges gegen die ukraine manche
sind eindeutig wir können auch einmal
frieren für die freiheit frieren für die
freiheit viele halten das für richtig
aber dennoch sagen sie ja ja aber aus
geopolitischer sicht sehen wir dass die
abhängigkeit von russland nicht nur uns
angreifbar macht sondern dass wir
dadurch auch mit unseren geldern diesen
krieg diesen furchtbaren angriffskrieg
von putin mitfinanzieren das wollen wir
nicht und das hat versuchen wir jetzt so
viel wie möglich zu reduzieren so
schnell wie möglich unabhängig zu werden
das aber liegt in dem wort unabhängig
werden wir sind es nicht und deshalb
waren viele ohne russische energie sind
wir alle betroffen es geht um viel mehr
als um es frieren die gefahr für
deutschland ist riesengroß ja oder nein
energieimporte stoppen schauen wir
genauer hin
[Applaus]
mein name ist britta buchholz und ich
versuche das moralische dilemma so
aufzudröseln dass ihr euch ein klares
bild machen könnt erst einmal die fakten
deutschland bezieht aus russland 55
prozent des gases 35 prozent des rohöls
und 50 prozent der kohle das sind
immense zahlen und was kostet das
experten meinen deutschland zahlt
mehrere hundert millionen euro täglich
manche schätzungen gehen davon aus dass
die eu eine milliarde euro zahlt täglich
ganz ehrlich da fassen wir uns doch an
den kopf wir belegen russland mit
massenhaften sanktionen und gleichzeitig
zahlen wir millionen für energie während
des krieges das kann doch gar nicht wahr
sein die bundesregierung in der
chefetage sagt doch stolz sagt ein
klares nein zu einem energie importstopp
ebenso außenministerin berbalk oder auch
wirtschaftsminister habeck aber diesen
widerspruch dieses ja aber dieses nein
aber das wird auch bei ihm deutlich ich
würde mich dagegen aussprechen weil wir
damit den sozialen frieden in der
republik gefährden wir zahlen ja jetzt
schon an der tankstelle und beim heizen
immense summen und dann zusätzlich
einfrieren für den frieden das ist ein
abwägen zwischen moral und verantwortung
moralische verantwortung für die ukraine
wirtschaftliche verantwortung für
deutschland auch innerhalb der parteien
sind sie sich überhaupt nicht einig
beispiel cdu in der cdu ist der
vorkämpfer norbert röttgen der
außenpolitiker ist für einen sofortigen
importstopp wir müssen wissen dass wenn
wir die gas und öl importe weiter
betreiben dann finanzieren wir auf
rekordniveau den krieg von putin gegen
das ukrainische volk ich habe ihnen in
der vergangenen woche interviewt also er
stand in seiner heimat an der dorfkirche
ein zdf kamerateam hatte vor ihm
aufgebaut und ich stellte ihn per
telefon die fragen seine forderung ist
klar nur wenn es um die risiken geht
dann schiebt er den schwarzen peter
weiter unsere versorgung ist
gewährleistet gesichert bis zum nächsten
winter die gasspeicher sind hinreichend
gefüllt das ist die aussage der
bundesregierung wenn die nicht stimmt
dann muss die bundesregierung sagen dass
sie die deutsche öffentlichkeit falsch
informiert hat ja in der union ist es
eben auch ein ja aber der ehemalige
röttgen konkurrent und jetzt
parteivorsitzende friedrich merz zum
beispiel der möchte den gashahn noch
nicht vollständig zu drehen und warnt
vor einem boykott die positionen
innerhalb der parteien gehen manchmal
weit auseinander wir bekommen allerdings
den fachlichen rat und nicht nehmen wir
an dass das zum jetzigen zeitpunkt keine
option sein sollte das würde sehr
kurzfristig zu größten problemen auch in
der versorgung unseres landes führen
auch in der versorgung der privaten
haushalte aber es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen dass es kommt es kann
sogar sein dass es von russischer seite
aus kommt also wir sollten auch darauf
vorbereitet sein ohne es selbst
auszulösen warum diese vorsicht das wort
dieser tage heißt versorgungssicherheit
zwar sind die gasspeicher wieder gefüllt
aber im nächsten winter wäre vor allen
dingen die industrie gefährdet der
bundeskanzler schickte am siebten märz
extra eine pressemeldung rum damit allen
klar ist die versorgung kann im moment
nicht anders gesichert werden soll
heißen ein importstopp könnte bedeuten
wir haben nicht mehr genug energien zur
verfügung eine woche später war ich bei
der pressekonferenz mit christian
lindner linda als fdp parteivorsitzender
und er meint erteilt die position von
scholz & harbeck und betont schon jetzt
muss es ein entlastungspaket geben schon
jetzt muss die industrie gestützt werden
und schon jetzt will er einen krisen
rabatt kraftstoff so nennt er das und es
klingt ein bisschen nach autofahrer
partei ein boykott jedenfalls lehnt er
ab und zwar deshalb auch wenn es
natürlich
immer noch eine option
ist diese option nicht genutzt werden
sollte weil unsere eigene
durchhaltefähigkeit harter sanktionen
möglicherweise geschwächt wird ohne dass
wir tatsächlich
signifikanten zusätzlichen druck auf
putin ausüben ok nehmen wir das mal aber
wie werden wir diese abhängigkeit los
wie könnte das klappen wie ist der plan
also da ist zum einen die kohle die
braunkohle bauen wir ja noch selbst ab
aber fast jeden monat geht an meiler vom
netz zwar oft mit einer art
notversorgung aber eigentlich läge doch
jetzt eine renaissance der dreckigen
cholera oder die ministerpräsidenten der
braunkohlegebiete jedenfalls machen
ordentlich druck wir haben
braunkohlekraftwerke die stabil arbeiten
und das darf jetzt nicht abgeschaltet
werden und damit noch mehr die
abhängigkeit von russischem gas erzeugt
werden wir müssen wir klug miteinander
nachdenken und ich wünsche mir da eine
wirkliche diskussion ohne scheuklappen
eigentlich um das mal klar zu sagen geht
es um eine zahl im koalitionsvertrag der
ampel steht nämlich ein beschleunigter
ausstieg aus der kohleverstromung soll
idealerweise bis 20.30 erfolgen das war
ja ein hart erkämpftes ziel der grünen
also diese 20.30 also in genau acht
jahren und genau darum wird jetzt
gestritten ob es nicht auch länger
dauern könnte viele grüne sind dagegen
bliebe noch die renaissance der
atomkraft drei kernkraftwerke hat
deutschland noch alle drei sollen ende
des jahres begraben werden der grüne
wirtschaftsminister harbeck prüft nun ob
sie länger am netz bleiben könnten die
betreiber signalisieren
gesprächsbereitschaft
söder ist dafür andere sagen das lohnt
sich überhaupt nicht ist es viel zu
kompliziert und viel zu unsicher hinter
den kulissen um es klar zu sagen sind
viele grüne entsetzt ausgerechnet die
atomkraft nein danke jetzt
atomkraftwerke wieder ans netz zu
bringen wie auch sicherheitsvorschriften
verzichten auf genehmigung verzichten
das kann doch am ende niemanden diesem
land ernsthaft wollen und eine
alternative für erdgas
schwierig es ging das so genannte
flüssiggas also lng das ließe sich per
schiff über das meer her schiffen käme
dann aus katar und den usa natürlich
auch keine umweltzone methode und
deutschland hat noch nicht einmal einen
geeigneten hafen der soll nun gebaut
werden und nun passt mal auf bauzeit
schätzungsweise drei bis fünf jahre und
zur wahrheit gehört ein weiteres dilemma
bei wir putins energien nicht mehr
wollen umwirbt der westen jetzt andere
autokratien gewechselt von einem
diktator dann sozusagen zum nächsten
wollen wir diese alternative qatar
venezuela saudi-arabien auch schwierig
eine lösung wären die erneuerbaren
energien ihr anteil nimmt ja stetig zu
aber die wahrheit ist auch bisher können
sie schwerlich russische importe
vollständig ausgleichen also wenn wir
uns ehrlich machen heißt das alles wenn
wir putin den gashahn zudrehen dann
bekommen wir erst einmal ein
riesengroßes problem wir können es mal
versuchen auf dem weltmarkt zuzukaufen
aber auch das ist nicht einfach kann
sehr kompliziert werden und wird
definitiv sehr sehr teuer bei twitter
streiten die ökonomen gerade darüber was
würde das denn wirklich bedeuten manche
warnen vor einer rezession und einem
massiven wachstumseinbruch hier zum
beispiel tom krebs der schreibt das ist
eine wirtschaftskrise ähnlich zur corona
krise nur mit sehr hoher inflation
andere stimmen ihm dazu und wieder
andere sagen das wird es schon werden
aber es lässt sich auch mit mehrkosten
ausgleichen aber am ende ist das alles
spekulation also ich versuche dass man
wirtschaftlich runter zu brechen wer was
von wirtschaft versteht kann jetzt
einfach eine minute vor spielen also
stellt euch ein unternehmen vor dass
schließanlagen herstellt also das sind
diese kleinen zylinder die man in die
tür rein macht wurde an unser schlüssel
reingesteckt wird eine schließanlage
kostet sagen wir mal fiktiv 50 euro
bisher bis vor einer woche generierte
das unternehmen 20 prozent des umsatzes
in russland das ist nun vorbei
umsatzeinbruch dazu kommt die
herstellungskosten des unternehmens
steigen deutlich da auch ein zulieferer
aus russland kam und nicht mehr liefern
kann und alle anderen zulieferer höhere
preise haben da die energiepreise ja
jetzt schon immens steigen bedeutet das
unternehmen hat höhere kosten aber
niedrigere einnahmen im fiktiven
beispiel verweigert deutschland die
annahme von gas öl kohle aus russland
das heißt stattdessen beziehen wir aus
anderen ländern teurer
eben diese energien und jetzt kommen wir
zu einem weiteren dilemma dass mit dem
beispiel auch zu tun hat denn china
könnte künftig günstig energie aus
russland beziehen und teuer an uns
verkaufen wir würden dann am ende doch
über umwege wieder rohstoffe aus
russland beziehen nur zu einem höheren
preis nun könnte die chinesische
konkurrenz ihre schließanlage stadt für
50 plötzlich für 35 euro anbieten
während die deutsche firma den preis
deutlich anheben müsste alles fiktiv
aber am ende agieren fast alle firmen
global und im globalen wettbewerb würde
eine sanktion unsererseits auf energie
massive auswirkungen haben für die
schließanlagen firma geht es nun real um
ihre existenz sowie für viele viele
andere firmen auch lobbyisten aus dem
bereich gas warnen deshalb deutlich herr
merz hat den stopp der nordstream 1
lieferungen ins spiel gebracht das wäre
für die deutsche wirtschaft ein sehr
sehr starker schlag es würde sofort
auswirkungen auf lieferketten auf
produktionsprozesse auch haben von daher
ist das ein vorschlag der sicherlich
nicht von der deutschen wirtschaft auch
mitgetragen wird nur was heißt das jetzt
alles wirtschaft vor moral sind wir
wieder bei christian lindner der meint
ein boykott würde an der situation also
dem krieg in der ukraine nichts
verändern nur unsere
verhandlungsposition wäre geschwächt
aber auch das umstritten tja und jetzt
ich habe den umweltökonomen andreas
löschel dazu befragt er berät auch das
wirtschaftsministerium
er warnt vor zu hohen preisen und drängt
auf den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
sein appell also man muss jetzt
eigentlich so planen
als ob es kein gas aus russland gäbe
entweder weil russland den gashahn zu
gemacht oder weil wir uns entschließen
eben kein gast mehr abzunehmen und ich
glaube jetzt ist tatsächlich das eine
politische entscheidung aber was
natürlich ein ganz massives signal wäre
auch an die russische seite frierend für
die freiheit müssen wir putin jetzt den
gashahn zudrehen ja oder nein was ist
eure meinung schreibt es in die
kommentare
und wenn euch die folge gefallen hat
last ein like da und abonniert unseren
kanal bei meinem letzten video gab es am
ende einen gag den gibt es heute nicht
die lage ist einfach zu ernst bis zum
nächsten mal